hey everybody welcome back to wonderium
now a show that highlights the best
series that wandrium has to offer I'm
rich Burnett and in today's show we'll
be discussing the Middle Ages around the
world so grab your favorite Mead and
trusty Steed we're about to travel back
in time
[Music]
today's guest is Joyce Salisbury Joyce
is a historian who has written hundreds
of Publications on medieval history her
latest series called the Middle Ages
around the world is available to stream
now on wandrium let's take a look
in the 5th Century the borders of the
Roman Empire were porous Germanic tribes
also called Gothic tribes had lived
beyond the borders of the empire for
years they traded served as mercenaries
and coexisted side by side for centuries
all that changed in the fifth century
when these tribes poured into the Empire
at first raiding then settling down as
allies or federates of the Roman Empire
the story of these invasions that
transformed the Empire actually begins
in the great steps of Central Asia
the steps are a vast area of grassland
extending from Eastern Europe near the
mouth of the Danube across to the
Pacific Ocean here the Bactrian camel
was domesticated about 5 000 years ago
and served as Transportation even across
the high deserts bordering the region
Joyce hello thanks for joining us hi
so I'd like to start off with some 101
level context if you don't mind when we
talk about the Middle Ages uh what time
period are we talking about
we're talking about a thousand years
from about 400 to 14 1450 from the fall
of the Roman Empire in the West in 476
to the fall of the Roman Empire in the
east in 1453 and in fact it was the 19th
century historians who loved the
Greco-Roman world and they loved the
Renaissance and they threw everything
else in between and they called it oh
that's just the middle and medieval
means Middle Ages and Latin typically
when you say the Middle Ages you know
people picture European castles and
knights but your series called the
Middle Ages around the world is just
that it's a global view of what was
happening during that time around the
world right right but it's also
something a bit more because the
historians in the 19th century thought
Europe was the center of the world and
defined the Middle Ages and knights and
Shining Armor
the center but you know what it was
always a global World always contact
between Europe but all the way to China
to Africa to India so what I wanted to
show was the Middle Ages is not a
European phenomenon it's a global one
all right and one of the things that you
discuss across the entire series is
religion so tell me a little bit about
some of the religions that really
flourished during this time period
this is such an important question
because the Middle Ages was rightly
called the age of faith and this was
true all over the world people were
expressing religious impulses of giant
upsurge of religion everywhere and it
transformed the future so here are some
of the religious impulses that we see
the Middle Ages started in the west
literally with the rise of Christianity
in 380 Christianity became the official
religion of the Roman Empire so from
then on they call themselves Christendom
the Christian West in the 7th Century
the prophet Muhammad had Visions in a
cave and he started a new religion Islam
right here Center in the Middle Ages
that spread and split the Mediterranean
world and went all the way to India and
Beyond
and then also from India Buddhists
spread Buddhism all the way out of India
across southeast Asia to China to Japan
so Buddhism spread and flourished
everywhere and so what you can see is
religion spread but when they do things
get very complicated I mean Christians
began to argue with each other and east
and west split Muslims began to argue
with each other and Sunni and Shiite
split Buddhists began to argue with each
other although Buddhists don't argue
very hard and you have Mahayana and
theraveda Buddhism so what I try to look
at in the course of these lectures is
how religions not only spread but as
they engage human hopes and fears and
expectations they change and transform
and become some of the highest
aspirations of human holes
so everyone loves a story about bad guys
who are some of the most despicable
characters from around the world during
the Middle Ages
on the top of my list
who was the Grand Inquisitor of Spain
he represented what I think is the worst
institution which is the Inquisition you
know this was a court that wanted to
know not what you did but what you
thought
so this is the thought Police Court and
he prosecuted it vigorously trying to
find if people sustained secret secret
Jewish ideas or sustained secret Muslim
ideas and so he was the what they call
the hammer of Heretics in Spain and he
is a perfect villain by trying to
torture people to reveal what they
thought when sometimes they didn't even
know what they thought so he's my
villain number one
next villain number two you might think
Genghis Khan or someone like that you
know who has a reputation but I'm gonna
go with Genghis Khan's son ogodai
because he was the first to
introduce Mass rape as a military
philosophy you know and if that's not
okay either so he gets my villain of the
Year award as well do you have a third
or are you going to leave it at that
lovable character let's let's hear your
third well the third is a little bit
more obvious Attila the hung sure he was
called the scourge of God because the
Christians couldn't figure out how God
could let such a ruthless person conquer
their cities and burn things down and
kill along the way so yeah Attila the
Hun he can get he can get my
third so let's say on the other side of
that coin who are some of the heroes of
this time now you know Heroes is a funny
thing too okay for me
I can't count as a hero for example
these great warriors who who maybe have
won a great battle but leave the blood
of Innocence running in the road okay so
they get all marked off my hero list and
so what I want are heroes who somehow
changed the way we look at the world for
the better right somehow that elevates
us and enhances us so here come my
Heroes all right how about avicena the
Muslim philosopher physician who had
this brilliant idea to think that maybe
illness has natural causes so we should
look at that and he wrote the Canon of
medicine that remained the main medical
text until the 18th century in the west
and Islam and with actually more
um editions of the can of medicine in
the west and any other book except the
Bible so avicenna as someone who wanted
to
Elevate People's Health he gets a point
on my totally good guy list
Juan Jung you might not have heard of
him but in the 7th Century he's a
Chinese man who went to India he
collected over 600 um Buddhist texts and
he had he put them all on Caravan and
went back across the Gobi desert and
brought them to China and it's because
of his introduction of these Buddhist
texts to China that Buddhism spread
dramatically in in China
yeah and I'm going to give you one more
I got yeah go for it because I couldn't
make up my mind which ones to choose so
I'm getting yeah all right I got a
Frenchman Abbott soujay he had a
different view of how people ought to
pray to God he thought you know light
that kind of light can Elevate us all
so he changed the architecture of the
cathedrals instead of Romanesque he
designed Gothic to let all the light in
and think of that the gothic Cathedrals
that spread all over Europe and Beyond
thanks to Abbott soujay and his vision
of light awesome three three good guys
in my world
thanks for uh balancing that out we
needed a palette cleanser
um so let's switch to the topic of
inventions of which there are many
during that time period so if you had to
choose let's stick with the number three
but if you had to choose your top three
inventions uh that came out of the
Middle Ages what would those be
windmills and water Mills it is I know
that sounds so terribly modern doesn't
it but the Roman Empire's power and
energy was built on slave labor of
people but the Middle Ages didn't have
that many people to to use so they
developed windmills that came out of
Persia by the way and spread all the way
windmills and water Mills there are um
for example Rivers like the River Thames
had a watermelt every mile to bring
power to the local people and not
electricity but for grinding mill and
for padding
cloth and and great
um one of the things that surprised me
was the effectiveness of tidal Mills so
as the tide comes in
the Mills turn and as it goes out the
Mills turn so this was really a
revolution in energy that was brought
about in the Middle Ages
and and I picked that one it was hard
you know there's horse collars and
wheelbarrows but I'm okay stick with the
middle okay here's number two
paper
think about paper to write before well
paper was invented in China and it came
and spread into Spain through North
Africa by the 11th 12th century so
before that if you wanted to write
something you had to use Vellum or
parchment
cow skins or sheepskins a gospel book
The Book of Kells for example took the
skins of 185 cats to make picture that
one book 185 cats so a book is a rare
thing but paper wow now you got and they
would pound the pulp of um bamboo or you
know wood or something and they pounded
it using water wheels and then you can
have paper you could have multiple
copies of books that are done readily
and you can have more paper spread and
paper in China there's a medieval
commentator he observed of course they
had paper money which they didn't in the
west and
this Observer sent look at this they
value paper as money and yet they use
paper in the bathroom during their
toilets sadly the third one is gunpowder
and vented at the end of the Middle Ages
dominated the Hundred Years War and it
was gunpowder with a great cannon that
brought down Constantinople in 1453
and destroyed the Middle Ages gunpowder
so it always helps us to understand
history you know when there are
parallels to our modern world we kind of
just touched on one almost but what if
anything is happening today that we
could look back at the Middle Ages and
say yeah they already covered this
okay first of all pandemic the Black
Death 1348 killed a third to a half of
people all the way from Europe
to Africa all the way to China so here's
a pandemic here are people who who saw
death coming but didn't know where it
came from I'm feeling very often like
that when I go out in this covet era you
know and what it also did was it showed
us that people stopped wanting to go to
work people were dropping out of their
jobs what's the point of working and
then and then they questioned hierarchy
what's the point of being
um subservient to those in charge if I'm
going to die of the plague anyway so
pandemic number one write off right off
the top they did it we're doing it right
number two dear to my heart
deforestation
I love trees
well who doesn't but here in the Middle
Ages they discovered that when they cut
all the trees in Greenland there was
nothing left they couldn't build a ship
they couldn't leave you know or Rapa Nui
Easter Island
deforested it everything went bad Chaco
Canyon also when you're cutting down
massive amounts of trees
you can't sustain it and they use the
trees I mean it's overwhelming when I
think about it for example the Tower of
London that great Stone Tower it took
500 oak trees to build the scaffolding
to raise the tower so the shape of the
land of the world changed changed
dramatically in China they deforested to
try to use charcoal so trees were coming
down everywhere and environmental damage
they they totally knew about that for
sure okay so my last one is global trade
I love it when I see the news and it
says oh well we're globalization I mean
this is a problem this is new now people
have always
traded globally always
um that's what we do one of those deep
characteristics that we have is we like
to shop and we like new things so we go
further and further afield to buy new
things we'll get pepper from India silk
from China
um
elephant tusks from Africa will get
things from all over the world and
sometimes in the Middle Ages the supply
chains the Silk Road was interrupted
with war and violence but didn't matter
people always traded globally and always
wanted to so when we're looking at
global trade internationalization supply
chain issues
old news
so I'm actually going to throw you a bit
of a curveball here this is on me but in
every episode I like to start off with a
corny little intro that refers to the
topic of the episode but man in this
show I I really struggled to come up
with some sort of terminology to bring
us into the show what kind of forms of
entertainment were popular during the
Middle Ages maybe I can come up with
something that that will fit the the the
intro the show uh based off of what you
can tell me
well one thing to know is we're so used
to entertainment being everywhere around
us and in our homes right our TVs our
computers our music but in the Middle
Ages you went out at least the common
people went out for entertainment but
there was also a sort of feast of fools
um and this needs a minute to explain
because in the Middle Ages people
believed that there was only a certain
amount of good
if you use up all the good you've run
out but equally there's only a certain
amount of chaos and if you use up all
the chaos you're good so in the Feast of
fools the beggar would become the king
people would dress up as animals to use
up and be wild and crazy to use up all
the chaos there was so there'll be less
chaos the rest of the year so
entertainment was outside it was built
to eliminate chaos and of course the
nobility like to practice their skills
they would joust and knock each other
off horses that was always a good time
you mentioned Renaissance Fairs the
Renaissance uh as you stated earlier
doesn't necessarily fit within the
Middle Ages but all these Modern
Renaissance Fairs they're less
renaissancey than they are medieval
so we're gonna go to a short break do
you mind sticking around no be fun
awesome
I'd like to take a quick moment to
remind you that Joyce is one of the
hundreds of great presenters we work
with at wandrium
in addition a series about life during
the Middle Ages you'll also find topics
like science mental health foreign
language instruction and personal
development there really is something
for everyone on wandrium go check them
out and tell them Rich sent you from the
Middle Ages
if you want to binge watch something
watch something that's smart buy experts
on biodiversity Mayan history
streaming is a lot smarter with one
dream one dream because I wonder
knowledge is now streaming at wandrium
all right Joyce thanks for sticking
around before we get to the next segment
I've got to ask you what is going on in
these pictures you sent me let's start
with this one here looks like you might
be sitting down in a in a red long
sleeve shirt of some sort with a black
vest and a black cap on what's going on
here well I ran when I was teaching we
ran a feast of fools a medieval Feast of
fools in part two articulate this chaos
reading and to let students bring the
past to life a little bit but so what I
did was in that one I'm reading the
tarot cards because in the Middle Ages
you had a decent Gypsy who would come
and read the tarot cards and tell your
future nice and I'm assuming here in the
second picture you sent you're doing the
same exact thing with a slightly
different outfit it looks like you've
got a a golden uh head scarf and a very
nice black uh dress of some sort with
with golden Stripes were these
historically accurate I tried you know
I'm not perfect I tried to use natural
fibers you know and I tried to do
something like that and yes another year
another Tarot deck I was really quite
popular with the tarot readings actually
I could have had it
did you study tarot cards did you know
what you were doing are you really good
at making it up as you went
I have studied the tarot cards as I was
trying to look trying to understand some
texts so yeah
I know
uh right the third picture here is uh
looks like a banquet table of some sort
you're in what looks like a peacock
green dress next to somebody who appears
to be a skeleton
Feast of fools this is a serious
straight up Feast of fools I presided
over the head table with Death By My
Side to enhance life you know and so we
had everybody drinking and eating and
the chancellor was a real sport he
dressed up as a popper and came begging
nice and like a version of the social
order which is always fun and it looks
like the fourth picture here might be
from the same night because you are in
the same outfit but you are it looks
like you're emceeing the event here what
do you think you're saying in this photo
what I'm saying is I'm introducing sword
fighters who came out and we had
choreographed a nice sword fight much to
the Chagrin of the liability people in
the office
but so they did a nice sword fight
so in researching my questions Joyce
um I I found that there's a lot of
enduring myths about the Middle Ages so
now with your permission I'd like to
play a little game for our audience here
that we're calling fact or fiction
Middle Ages Edition are you ready I'm
ready
all right so let's start with this one
fact or fiction people do not live past
30 years old in the Middle Ages fact or
fiction total fiction in fact that
number it's it's a mathematical number
so when you have um sort of age
range lots of children died and then
when you average it out then the average
lifespan becomes 30. not because people
died at 30 but because lots of children
died and excused the average as a matter
of fact there were plenty of us old
gray-haired leaders in the Middle Ages
I'll give you an example of one the doje
of Venice who was in his 90s suffering
from cataracts led the Fourth Crusade as
it attacked Constantinople
wow all right let's move on to number
two fact or fiction medieval people
thought the Earth was flat
so fiction I mean
anybody who lives let's say near the
shore like the Mediterranean or any of
the other coasts you know when you see a
ship coming you can see it coming above
the Horizon the only explanation for
that
is around Earth the same thing if you
were in the plains the Great Plains of
Central Asia if you look toward the
Horizon it's 26 miles away so then you
see people coming Warriors coming over
the horizon they knew the Earth was
round but they didn't know was that it
moved that's what freaked them out
eventually in the Scientific Revolution
we've got Galileo in trouble they
believe the Earth is still and the stars
and the Sun and the Moon circulates
around it but we were still
so here's
round but still
um that that's a description for uh me
during quarantine all right fact or
fiction Vikings War horned helmets
total fiction the horned helmets were
invented by Wagner in the 19th century
so they would look cool in his Opera but
if you think about it just for a minute
a helmet is for a sword to be deflected
off your head what are you gonna do let
it get caught in a horn so it can
actually break through the helmet no no
hell no horns they save their horns for
drinking
um fear and wine beer and Mead out of
their horns not for fighting
let's go to number four or five I've
lost count and they're not numbered on
my cards with fact or fiction medieval
people drank wine and beer because water
was so polluted
totally fiction first thing you have to
know is that in most places the water
wasn't polluted okay downtown
London where the Thames and people were
dumping
carcass is in fine but no they in fact
watered their wine to dilute it some why
did they drink beer and wine because it
preserved all the grain so it becomes a
way to preserve grapes a way to preserve
grain so then you could have a
substantial portion of your calories
from beer and wine from the preserved
food you're not wasting anything
here's another one sort of along the
same lines Factor fiction people had
poor hygiene and never bathed in the
Middle Ages
fiction been watching too many medieval
movies right with people all dirty right
a mud all over your your clothes are all
nasty
so they absolutely love their baths you
would come and you would have a bath and
we have like particularly from the
Vikings some wonderful little cleaning
tools on like a keychain to clean your
earwax and you know to brush and comb to
make sure very hygienic in fact they
loved their baths so much that public
baths like in London and Southern became
places to pick up prostitutes so lots of
fun in the bath
you need to be clean for uh certain
events all right last one on the list
fact or fiction in 70 France 1457 a sow
was charged with murder found guilty and
hanged
absolutely fact
I know and I love that you asked me this
because I have actually written on this
subject in my book The Beast Within
here's the thing at the end of the
Middle Ages well first let me ask you
might ask why'd they do that right
they're treating uh
felonious Sal who by the way her crime
was to eat a baby all right not not the
done thing but but treating a felonious
foul in the criminal courts instead of
just bringing an ax and chopping her in
the late Middle Ages people were afraid
afraid of what not a felonious sow they
were always pigs that threatened
children but afraid that their own
Humanity might be lost if they acted too
much like an animal and then by the same
token these animals seemed very human
you know you're living close to a pig
maybe the thing is it's not just a pig
maybe it's acting like a human so
therefore we should put it on trial so
everybody would notice so the other pigs
will be
put on notice that such goings-on
weren't allowed and they actually paid
we have the records that show they paid
more for the Executioner than a butcher
would have cost them they hired a
defense attorney whose plea was that the
animal didn't know what she was doing
you know and and they finally hung her
as they would
a criminal so your knowledge was this
done tongue-in-cheek or was it done in
all seriousness oh there were a bunch of
them this is not the only one I mean
between about 1400 up to 1700 there were
hundreds of animals put on trial
so by the way you just gave me a new
band name uh felonia sow I'm gonna go
ahead and start a new punk band in my
mid-40s my kids will be horrified
um so cool well it turns out that no you
can't believe everything that you read
online who would have thought uh so
Joyce they're going to wrap it up here
thank you so much for joining me
thanks it was fun great so where can
people go to find out more about you and
the work that you do well they can come
to my Facebook page Joyce e Salisbury
where I occasionally post what's going
on in my life and you could look up my
lectures on one dream of course and
finally take a look at my latest book
The Beast Within and learn more about
the felonious Sal
awesome I'm going to do that uh thank
you so much and I'll talk to you again
soon okay
and that'll do it for another episode of
wondering now if you want to see more of
Joyce check out our Tick Tock we'll be
back soon with another great show be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss it